here's the fact when Donald Trump talks
about judgment what was his position on
who had been the best negotiator to deal
with Iran it wasn't a Republican it was
Hillary Clinton that's what you believe
I mean the lack of judgment and the lack
of understanding about how the world
works is really dangerous in this kind
of time that we're saying so is that the
judgment that you bring to the table the
hit early Clint he's a creep initiator
that she could bring about a better your
brother and your brother's
administration gave us Barack Obama
because it was such a disaster those
last three months that Abraham Lincoln
couldn't have been elected you know what
as a relates to my brother there's one
thing I know for sure he kept us safe I
don't know if you remember
you remember the
the rubble remember the firefighter that
is wrong around it we sent a clear
signal that the United States would be
strong and fight Islamic terrorism and
he did keep us safe I don't know you
feel safe right now I don't feel so safe